SAVANNAH MAZIYA: I think the
smartest people in the world
are people who are going to be
looking to invest in Africa.
Africa as a whole is really very well
known as a resource-rich environment.
ROBERT BROZIN: We knew nothing
about the restaurant business.
And my original intention was really
to do it as part of a pure investment.
JAMES MWANGI: We're
able to digitize that.
We're be able to create
algorithms because we
have data spanning thirty years.
There has been a lot of
movement or transformation.
Very micro businesses becomes more--
more businesses become medium.
Medium become large enterprises.
And large enterprises are corporatizing.
SAVANNAH MAZIYA: You can't
keep pointing fingers
and say someone's going
to come and save the day.
You have to, in your own
way, figure out a way
to lead and let others
join you or assist you.
But be part of that solution.
JAMES MWANGI: They are
in the driver's seat.
We're just empowering them
to change their lives.